England, June fifth, nineteen forty-four.
Four paratroop officers stand beside an aircraft, looking
down at their wrists.
They are synchronizing their watches.
In a few hours, they will jump into occupied France.
Before the beaches, before the landing ramps, the invasion
begins with a shared time.
The photograph survives. A small ritual, almost swallowed
by the scale of what comes next.
This is the story behind the watch that saved D-Day:
how something small enough to wear on a wrist helped
people carry an enormous plan into battle.
But the real test comes after the watches agree.
What happens when the timetable meets the enemy?
To understand that photograph, step back from the
aircraft. The Normandy invasion is a collection of moving
parts: ships crossing the Channel, aircraft overhead,
troops dropping behind the coast, and landing craft
approaching five beaches. Each part has a job.
Each job has a place in the sequence.
Airborne troops must secure key objectives before the
seaborne assault reaches the shore.
Ships must support the landings.
Fresh waves must follow the first.
Imagine a railway timetable in which the tracks move,
the stations shoot back, and the weather can close the
whole network. That is an analogy.
The real problem is harder.
The operation has to bring separate forces into the same
battle at useful moments.
And the Channel sets a deadline nobody can negotiate.
The tide.
At low tide, more of the beach is exposed.
So are the obstacles placed to damage or destroy
approaching boats. That helps the teams sent to
clear them. But it also leaves soldiers farther from
cover, crossing open ground under fire.
At high tide, the water carries boats closer to shore.
It can also hide the hazards in their path.
There is no perfect setting.
The Army and Navy have competing needs, and the planners
must find a workable compromise.
Darkness offers protection on the approach.
Daylight helps the bombardment and the assault.
The tide determines what can be seen, reached, or cleared.
Move the hour, and the whole arrangement changes.
On a watch face, an hour looks like a small distance.
On this coast, it changes the battlefield.
Now add the one thing the planners cannot schedule.
The invasion is initially planned for June fifth.
Then the weather turns against it.
The forecasting teams are led by James Stagg, the chief
meteorological adviser to Allied commander Dwight
Eisenhower. Their task is to judge whether the conditions
will let the operation proceed.
Strong winds and cloud threaten a plan that already
depends on a delicate combination of sea and sky.
Eisenhower postpones the invasion.
A timetable prepared for one day now has to move to
another. The delay is necessary, but it cannot continue
indefinitely: the useful combination of tides and light
returns only in limited windows.
Stagg and his colleagues identify a brief improvement for
June sixth. The conditions will still be marginal.
Eisenhower decides to proceed.
The date is settled.
Now thousands of separate movements must catch up with it.
Back at the aircraft, the officers bring their watches
into agreement. The National Army Museum identifies
them as pathfinders preparing to fly into battle.
Their role is to go ahead and help mark the landing zones
for the troops who follow.
This is what makes the wristwatch interesting.
A written order can tell you when something should happen.
A watch lets you compare that instruction with the moment
you are living through.
If two people use different times, an agreed appointment
becomes two different appointments.
Synchronization gives the plan a common reference.
It is a simple idea, illustrated here with a few moving
hands. Its consequences become very different when the
appointment is behind enemy lines.
The watches agree. The aircraft leave.
And the invasion moves into darkness.
In the early hours of June sixth, airborne troops begin
landing behind the coast.
On the British side, glider-borne troops seize the bridge
later known as Pegasus Bridge.
Other troops attack the battery at Merville.
These objectives form part of the effort to protect the
invasion's eastern flank. Farther west,
American paratroopers descend behind the beaches.
The drops are badly scattered.
Darkness, weather, and the difficulty of the operation
pull men away from the neat shapes on the planning maps.
A watch can tell a soldier the time.
It cannot tell him exactly where he has landed, gather his
missing unit, or remove the enemy ahead.
The timetable still matters.
But keeping the operation alive now demands judgment
and initiative. And while the fighting spreads
inland, dawn brings the next deadline toward the coast.
H-hour is the reference point for the assault: the
scheduled moment the first wave reaches the beach.
For the American beaches, it is six thirty in the morning.
Gold and Sword are scheduled later, at seven twenty-five.
Different conditions require different times.
Even this enormous coordinated attack does not work to one
identical starting gun. Before the landings, naval
guns fire on the defenses.
Landing craft move toward shore.
Troops and equipment follow in successive waves.
The sequence has to connect.
A unit arriving late can meet a different tide, a
different obstacle, or a different situation from the one
its orders anticipated. The wristwatch is one
way a person keeps track of that moving sequence.
It works inside a larger system of clocks, signals,
navigation, and command. On the beaches, that system is
about to face its harshest test.
At Omaha, demolition teams work to open passages
through the beach obstacles.
They are racing the rising water while under enemy fire.
A wartime report records six complete gaps opened
during the assault low tide, most by thirty minutes
after H-hour. It also records support teams
arriving twenty to sixty minutes late.
Those are the numbers of a plan under pressure.
The sea keeps moving while people load boats, reach shore,
lay charges, and fight for their lives.
No command can order the tide to wait.
The cleared gaps give following craft routes through the
barriers. Each passage connects the first assault to the
forces coming behind it.
Here, timing becomes visible.
It is water climbing an obstacle.
It is the shrinking chance to finish a job before the
conditions change. And it explains the quiet ritual
beside the aircraft.
Look again at the four officers checking their watches.
The photograph shows synchronization.
It does not identify a single miracle watch or prove that
one brand decided the battle.
Its power is simpler.
Each man is taking a common reference with him into a
place where he will have to act without seeing the whole
operation. That is the thread connecting this small
image to the ships and beaches: a plan becomes
useful when people can translate it into action.
Shared time helps them do that.
The operation still depends on forecasters, navigators,
crews, engineers, and soldiers.
The schedule breaks in places.
People adapt. But synchronization gives separate actions
a way to fit together, even across distance.
The watch is small.
The network around it is enormous.
By the end of D-Day, the Allies have established a
foothold in Normandy. The fighting is far from over.
That morning has demanded courage on a scale a timetable
cannot measure. Calling this the watch that saved
D-Day is a way of seeing an overlooked tool inside the
story. The documented contribution is coordination:
helping people carry shared time into a vast operation.
The watches did not win the battle for them.
They helped put a plan within reach, one glance at a wrist
at a time. The men in the photograph could agree on the
hour. What came after it depended on them, and on
thousands of others. Small hands on a dial.
Human hands that had to finish the job.